[Music]
tick tock star cooper noriega has died
he was 19 years old
here's what we know cooper's body was
found in a car in the parking lot at a
los angeles area mall on thursday the la
county department medical coroner tells
e.t that cooper was pronounced dead at
the scene and that his cause of death
has not been determined but foul play is
not suspected at this time
[Music]
just hours before he died cooper posted
this cryptic video on tick tock that's
him lying in bed with the caption who
else be thinking they gonna die young af
always told me i was different
cooper has nearly 2 million followers on
tick tock he's known for uploading lip
syncs modeling clips and dance collabs
often including good friends like jayden
hostler and nessa barron
[Music]
mental health also came up a lot on
cooper's feet he discussed battling
mental illness and substance abuse with
his followers i started like doing drugs
at like like 12 like vaping and i
started smoking at 13
and stuff and then like four teams when
it got really bad with like the
prescriptions and and everything yeah at
15 i like had an overdose and like
um but you had an overdose and then got
sent away to like wilderness therapy
that's cooper back in march opening up
on the good boys podcast a year and a
half ago almost
or about like a year and two months like
i'd like had like this just
it was like i was like 18 because i'm 19
i'm about to turn 20 in june
but i just had this crazy week of like
you know a bunch of drugs and i just
like had this moment of clarity where i
was just like it's just like really not
it's really not worth it anymore you
know i mean like i've been doing this
for like years now and like it was it
was so bad so i just like honestly i
just fully went like cold turkey like
nice i just like stopped everything he
talked a bit more about it all in a
youtube video explaining why he was
proud to share his struggles i post like
videos about like my drug addiction and
everything that i struggle with and i
get a lot of dm saying thank you so much
like you helped me tremendously i'm so
glad like you're vocal about this
because no one else it's like an amazing
feeling